wie ist die lage am ballermann da habe
ich vor der entscheidung tatsächlich
lokale an der schinkenstraße und an der
bierstraße zu schließen
mit ballermann star easy glück
gesprochen herzlich willkommen in der
sendung ja wie stehen sie zu diesen
bildern sind das einzelfälle oder droht
doch ein bisschen gefahr
hallo erstmal ja also das hier zurück
arien einfach noch mal sagen kann
ich sehe das so ein bisschen auch aus
der sicht von meinem künstlerkollegen
einem klausel den wir eben gerade auf
der bühne gesehen haben will wird er
jetzt in den sozialen medien teilweise
ein bisschen als sündenbock dafür hin
gestellt wobei man da immer sagen muss
einem clausen wurde gebucht weil ich als
künstler muss mich natürlich darauf
verlassen wenn ich gebucht werden dass
da alles geregelt ist entweder von der
regierung und natürlich auch vom
veranstalter dass da eben maßnahmen
geschaffen wurden dass ich auch
auftreten kann ohne dass ein risiko
besteht natürlich sind solche bilder
nicht schön zu sehen und diese partys
sollten natürlich in der form aktuell so
nicht stattfinden was das thema ist
genug mallorca angeht das kann man finde
ich nicht so ganz vergleichenden auf
mallorca feiern die meisten hier wenn
sie überhaupt feiern also man muss
wirklich viel suchen und lange suchen
bis man vielleicht eine kleine party
irgendwo finden kann und wenn dann ist
es meistens im freien und ischgl war ja
wirklich dicht gedrängt und vielen
kleinen bitten
und da ist glaube ich auch noch mal ein
großer unterschied also das kann ich gut
verstehen natürlich ist der interpret
oder der star des abends nicht für die
party verantwortlich
du sagtest es gibt da nur vereinzelt
partys trotzdem machen sich gerade die
gastronomen große sorgen dass die
behörden da hart durchgreifen
was glaubst du wie geht es da weiter
also heute hatten wir gerade in der
große demonstration in palma wo ich auf
alle haben geführt party mit kontrolle
demonstriert es geht darum dass wir
wirklich in magaluf oder playa de palma
uns etwas diskriminiert fühlen weil wir
hier natürlich gar keine möglichkeit
haben klubs zu öffnen obwohl es auch dem
rest der insel schon teilweise erlaubt
ist und wir haben heute dafür
demonstriert dass man eben doch große
läden eröffnen kann damit man partys mit
kontrolle über die bühne bringt weil wir
sehen ja die leute wollen sich treffen
das treffen sich vielleicht draußen am
strand oder in den straßen irgendwo und
dann wäre es doch besser ich habe eine
große party hochburgen wie den megapark
öffnen zu können wo man den platz und
die gegebenheiten hat das eben alles gut
zu kontrollieren und wie sehen sie das
persönlich natürlich wenn sie auf der
bühne stehen stehen natürlich ganz klar
die leute eng an
das wird sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
großartig ändern sehen sie das
entspannter oder geht es auch
tatsächlich ihnen darum dass die leute
ja disziplinierter feiern
ich muss sagen was nicht beobachter
haben die leute hier und die touristen
tatsächlich ein hohes maß an
eigenverantwortung also auch wenn ich
jetzt partys in deutschland mache es
gibt ja schon inzwischen die ein oder
andere packten anstaltung entweder auto
party oder letztens auch in bremen sind
die lockerung schon so weit
fortgeschritten dass man tatsächlich
wieder mit publikum feiern konnte aber
es haben sich wirklich alle sehr gut
dran gehalten das war wie eine sitzt
jeder anderen tische aufgebaut wo die
leute sitzen bleiben mussten
und das hat mit der entsprechenden
security eben auch ganz gut funktioniert
und darum geht es uns eben an der playa
de palma auf denn das kommt touristen
und die leute wollen vielleicht ausgeht
und sich treffen mit den leuten und
deswegen halte ich das für sehr wichtig
leider stößt man leider so ein bisschen
auf granit oder man meist auch gar nicht
weil man die regierung damit irgendwie
nicht so richtig erreicht sind auch die
gastronomen vielleicht daran schuld die
vielleicht das zu wenig security im
einsatz haben und natürlich wenn der
alkohol fließt dann ist es natürlich
auch schwer eine große gruppe zu
kontrollieren
ich glaube die gastronom selber die
waren selber überrannt ich weiß es gibt
diese videos wo man jetzt denkt oh gott
hier ist total ausnahmezustand irgendwie
in der bierstraße war es relativ cool
das war tatsächlich der eine abend so
dass die gastronomen und die ganze die
straße einfach glaube ich einfach ein
bisschen überrannt und überfordert war
aber ich meine jeder muss ich mir diese
situation erst mal so ein bisschen
einkaufen keiner hat schon mal eine
pandemie von uns erlebt und so gut die
gastronomen als auch die touristen
müssen jetzt erst mal gucken wie gehen
wir damit um und der eine abend war
tatsächlich leicht überfüllt aber am
nächsten abend war ich tatsächlich auch
vor ort und habe gesehen dass es schon
viel besser funktioniert hat da wurden
dann maßnahmen ergriffen dass eben doch
die leute sitzen bleiben unter kontrolle
sind
also es ist wirklich schwer hier eine
party gaal zu finden und ich weiß wenn
man das haar in der suppe sucht dann
findet man immer irgendwas aber aktuell
ist die lage hier tatsächlich sehr ruhig
und entspannt muss ich sagen da frage
ich am camp gibt euch einen ausrutscher
gysi hat es gesagt natürlich kennt
keiner die situation und wenn halt da
gefeiert wird hier wie will man das
unterbinden
aber natürlich es geht natürlich
mittelfristig darum dass auch in den
griff zu bekommen oder absolut und ich
kann das ep121 unterschreiben was sie so
glücklich sagt es gibt einfach nichts zu
den mars
und von da ist das vollkommen
verständlich ist auch für die
gastronomen verständlich dass manchmal
die situation aus dem ruder läuft und
man gar nicht so recht weiß wie man da
gegensteuern usw
aber das ist eben genau das problem und
das ist auch die herausforderung
und da müssen alle zusammenreißen und
auch diejenigen die feiern bei allem
verständnis ich fahre auch gerne aber
das ist eben das was eben das auch so
schwer macht auch genau für das was wir
jetzt gehört haben auch mal auch auf den
einzelnen spots ist es natürlich schwer
da zurück zu lockerungen herbeizuführen
wenn diese bilder um die welt gehen das
ist halt wirklich das problem weil wir
immer auch eine verantwortlichkeit der
örtlichen behörden haben auch natürlich
der bürgermeister auch der wir haben
mitarbeiter vor ort die genau dafür
verantwortlich sind und da ist eben
genau das problem von drakonischen
strafen ist die rede
masken pflicht war einer der ersten
schritte auch da sagen uns urlauber da
hält sich so gut wie keiner dran die ist
auch wirklich sehr sehr streng also
wahrscheinlich wird es dann auch in
zukunft mehr polizeikontrollen geben sie
was hältst du von dieser masken pflicht
jetzt außerhalb des strand ist also auf
der promenade braucht man keine maske
aber natürlich wenn ich durch die straße
gehe muss ich eine maske tragen
er unterbreite tatsächlich die erste
nachricht komplett masken pflicht
überall auch an der promenade und so
weiter das gut dann erst am tag oder am
nachmittag wieder doch ein bisschen
zurückgenommen und das war wirklich
nicht mehr ganz verhältnismäßig
grundsätzlich kann ich es nachvollziehen
dass die masken vielleicht ein bisschen
verschärft wird aber man muss auch
betonen das hat nichts damit zu tun was
in der bierstraße passiert ist sondern
es wurde schon vorher entschieden dass
die masse nicht verschärft wird aufgrund
von corona explosion in galicia und dem
festland von spanien und von daher ist
es natürlich sehr vernünftig und ich
kann es auch nachvollziehen dass sie
maßgeblich verschärft wird allerdings
ist es natürlich für jeden der das kennt
sehr unangenehm auch in den heißen
temperaturen mit maske rumzulaufen aber
wie gesagt am strand an der promenade
zum beispiel braucht es ja nicht mehr
tragen sie glück vielen dank für diese
einschätzung
toll dass du das eingeordnet hass und
ist es immer wichtig dass wir auch
wirklich vor ort nachfragen wie die lage
dort ist vielen dank easy glück er gerne